[Aplausos]
[Música]
Bienvenidos a diario del mundial el
programa de France 24 donde actualizamos
y analizamos el día a día de la Copa
Mundial de la FIFA
Qatar 2022 a continuación nuestros
titulares
Francia imparable la selección de
venció a Polonia y se clasificó a los
cuartos de final de la Copa del Mundo el
partido fue histórico para Olivia giró
quien se convirtió en el máximo anotador
para el combinado francés Tenemos
reporte desde Qatar
Inglaterra la cual subcampeona de Europa
venció a senegal y se clasificó a los
cuartos de final ahora enfrentará a
Francia en dicha instancia en una
reedición de la Guerra de los 100 días
pero esta vez en 90 minutos
[Música]
con los vuelos entre Japón y Croacia
Además del Brasil Corea del Sur continúa
en este lunes los octavos de final en la
Copa del Mundo de Qatar la duda jugará
Neymar este partido tenemos análisis y
reporte de este catálogo
para analizar el acontecer de cada
jornada Contamos con la presencia de
Octavio saso periodista de la emisora
Blu radio en Colombia bienvenido Octavio
Hola Luis un gusto saludarte como
siempre También aprovecho para darle la
bienvenida a nuestro enviado especial a
Juan pupiales quien nos trae todos los
detalles de primera mano de lo que está
ocurriendo en
Qatar saludos Juan
Luis Octavio Hola a todos un placer como
siempre estar aquí desde doja con esta
información nuestra compañera Natalia
Ruiz también desde Qatar se incorporará
más adelante iniciamos la selección
francesa demostró este domingo que es
una de las candidatas a estar por lo
menos en la final de la presente edición
de la copa del mundo los dirigidos por
titierrez champs actuales campeones del
torneo al ganar en Rusia 2018 se
apoyaron en la velocidad habilidad y
experiencia de sus jugadores como kilian
mbappé Oliver girot este último que hizo
un hecho histórico al frente de la
selección además de Antoine griezmann y
Compañía para derrotar a Polonia
selección de Robert lewandowski tres
goles por uno para conocerte detalles de
este partido vamos de inmediato a Qatar
con el reporte de nuestra enviada
especial Natalia Ruiz
Argentina tiene a Messi y Francia tiene
a kilian mbappé y a Olivia es
revoluciones de la victoria de Francia
tres goles por uno ante Polonia aquí en
el estadio alto mama fue un partido
bastante difícil muy físico sobre todo
en el primer tiempo con unos polacos que
salieron muy bien parados sobre el
terreno de juego y sobre todo bloqueando
Gracias a todos los embates ofensivos de
Francia por el carril izquierdo
justamente por allí donde está kilian
mbappé sin embargo Francia encontraría
ya el gol en el minuto 44 en el segundo
tiempo Francia se le vio mucho más
sólida controlando aún más el balón y
así de esta manera llegó el segundo gol
con una jugada que parte de griezmann la
dayu quien controla muy bien la pelota
la pasada dembélé y dembélé sirve a
mbappé el tercer gol vendría en el
minuto 91 con un pase de Johan para
mbappe doblete entonces de los número
diez de Francia y Polonia que pudo
descontar ya en los últimos instantes
por un penalti una mano de upamecano el
área penalti que además tuvo que hacer
repetido la primera vez y lloris pudo
tapar ese ese cola DEA lewandowski pero
en la segunda en la nueve de Polonia no
falló y Bueno finalmente se va con dos
goles marcados en este mundial
lewandowski Francia pasa entonces a
cuartos de final y con este tanto de
Bolivia llevo pues este hombre se
convierte en el mejor goleador en la
historia de los franceses con 52 tantos
Muchísimas gracias a Natalia Ruiz por
ese reporte pero Octavio podríamos decir
que las individualidades y la
experiencia le dieron el triunfo a
Francia sobre Polonia que por momentos
complicó el compromiso Sí por supuesto
Luis Polonia salió evidentemente a
buscar la posibilidad de que le pudiese
entregar el partido de ganarle a Francia
que era muy pocas realmente pero Polonia
sabía que tenía que hacer el un partido
brillante para poder derrotar al equipo
de líder de champs tenía que ser el
mejor partido de ellos en la copa del
mundo y eso hizo en el primer tiempo
sobre todo cuando intentó atacar frente
al arco de Hugo lloris lo que pasa es
que a medida que pasaba el tiempo
Francia siguió haciendo más fuerte el
desgaste evidente de Polonia frente a un
rival de las características de Francia
iba a pasar factura Y fue lo que terminó
sucediendo luego cuando aprovechó las
individualidades del equipo francés para
generarle a a Polonia dolores de cabeza
y terminar sacando los tres puntos en un
en un partido clave para el seleccionado
francés a partir de eso Francia empieza
a dominar el partido tiene mucha
jerarquía ya lo contaba Natalia Más allá
de lo de girú o lo de mbappé la
posibilidad de manejar la pelota en la
mitad de la cancha con shamini digamos
el juego que genera genera Francia desde
ahí también los movimientos de griezmann
y la capacidad que tiene de abrir el
partido del seleccionado galo fue lo que
terminó digamos haciendo Mella en el en
la defensa de polaca para que no
resistiera y tuviese que abrirse y poder
así Francia llevarse los tres goles que
que termina marcando el gol final es un
accidente del partido el partido incluso
pudo haber terminado con más goles para
el seleccionado francés y al final
Francia muestra porque es la gran
favorita de todos para llevarse
nuevamente la Copa del Mundo quizás ese
dato es el que está preocupando le han
anotado en todos los partidos a la
selección francesa en lo que va de copa
del mundo pero quisiera hacer un inciso
para hablar un poco de kilian mbappé
sabemos que cada generación tiene un
jugador diferente que destaca por encima
de los demás pero kilian parece tener
todo para triunfar por el tiempo que él
se proponga el jugador se convirtió en
el más joven que llega al 9 goles en el
menor tiempo dentro de copas del mundo
con 23 años y 349 días superando así al
portugués eusebio quien lo había hecho
con 24 años y 182 días en la copa de
1966 ahora va tras el récord de Máximo
anotador en copas del mundo ya tiene
nueve cinco han sido en este torneo que
aún no termina por su juventud podría
disputar al menos un par de copas más y
ya tiene dos el máximo anotador en todos
los tiempos espero las clases con 16
dianas Octavio Qué hace de especial a
este jugador Será su físico Será su
habilidad será la agilidad mental que ha
mostrado también para encarar el arco y
poder anotar y además de la de la
velocidad Luis es sin duda alguna dentro
de esta copa del mundo el jugador más
veloz y además el el tiene la capacidad
para pensar en esa velocidad y Y eso es
lo que realmente marca diferencia cuando
él Ya piensa la jugada que va a ser el
resto de Los Defensores todavía no se
han dado cuenta que él tiene la pelota
Entonces al pensar en esa velocidad al
jugar con esa velocidad hace que los
demás se vean realmente lentos cuando
estamos hablando de fútbol de élite es
algo parecido a lo que en su momento
tenía el pibe valderrama por ejemplo que
pensaba a una velocidad superior al
resto Y que cuando él ya iba a dar el
pase los demás se quedaban mirando la
velocidad física y mental de kilian
mbappé es superior a la del resto de sus
rivales Y eso hace que sea un jugador
digamos que hoy esté por encima de la de
la media además bueno la capacidad de
Gol que tiene la visión de juego el el
estar siempre bien ubicado Fíjate que
normalmente tú tomas a mbappé y siempre
tiene un espacio en el primer gol está
claro está claro eso mbappé recibe la
pelota muchísimo espacio porque en vez
de correr como Oliver girl él se quedó
parado y Recibió la pelota con espacio
para luego definir eso es lo que hace
que que él sea un jugador excepcional y
sin duda la gran figura de este mundial
ahora quisiera ir a Qatar con Juan Juan
cómo está supiendo kylian mbappé esta
copa vemos que se erige como el líder de
esta selección entre una serie de
jugadores que cuentan con mayor
experiencia que la
de lo que transmiten mbappé es que es un
jugador que se siente muy cómodo jugando
nada menos y nada más que en la élite
del fútbol en los mundiales que un
jugador de 23 años lleve 9 goles en Dos
copas mundos es un dato que es casi que
muy difícil de comparar Messi lleva
cinco mundiales y mbappé ya tiene un
mongol más que él en una copa mundo y
eso recalcando Por ejemplo que Messi
tuvo un mundial el de Sudáfrica en el
que no marcó en papel también tiene más
goles que Cristiano Ronaldo y esto yo lo
explico en que hay jugadores que se
sienten más cómodos en algunos torneos
que en otros hablando esto en un tema
fuera del fútbol me explicaba una vez
Andrés Gómez hablando de lo que pasa con
Rafael Nadal Cuando juega Roland garros
hay deportistas que en determinados
ambientes se crecen se sienten que están
en casa eso es lo que pasa con mbappé en
los mundiales siente que es un torneo
digamos fetiche que se le da bien y
sumando a lo que decía Octavio estar
aquí parece que le permite el tomar las
mejores decisiones volviendo a hablar de
ese primer gol los centrales polacos
esperan que el recorte hacia afuera
cuando está en el área y solamente le
dejan una ventana para que si puede tira
puerta mbappé Confía en su capacidad
para rematar a puerta y tiene las
cualidades para rematar en esa situación
complicada y lo hace bien Todo le sale
bien a mbappé en este mundial
en otro duelo de la jornada la selección
de Inglaterra superó tres goles por cero
a su similar de senegal para acceder de
esta manera los cuartos de final Jordan
Anderson a los 38 Harry King en el
agregado la primera parte y bocayo saca
marcaron en este compromiso para la
selección inglesa Juan en las tribunas
los senegaleses pusieron sabor pusieron
ritmo pusieron alegría pero los goles lo
que terminan valiendo llegaron por el
lado de los ingleses que decir del
funcionamiento de Inglaterra equipo que
si bien de ellos no se habla mucho pero
siempre se tienen ahí como candidatos
posibles pero también suelen fallar en
momentos claves
Oye mira lo de los senegaleses hablando
del conjunto africano Para empezar es
impresionante literalmente apoyan
durante todo el encuentro con una
vatocada que va desde el comienzo hasta
el final hablando de Inglaterra
grandísimo partido el de hoy sobre todo
porque hubo un muy buen muy muy muy buen
juego colectivo perdón y si buscamos una
estrella podemos nombrar a varias
podemos nombrar a que fue la amo y señor
del centro del campo podemos nombrar a
Harry kane podemos nombrar a Henderson a
buscar yo saca hubo un muy buen
movimiento colectivo hoy por parte de
este conjunto británico yo destacó mucho
lo de Harry King que juega con mucha
veteranía que fue el líder en el ataque
él comienza la jugada del primer gol
llevándose la marca hacia una banda
luego dándose pase profundidad para
belingham quien asistió a Henderson una
hermosísima combinación Henderson quien
esa celebración con bellingham le dice
con palabras vulgares le dice Me encantó
lo que hiciste porque la asistencia de
bellingham fue preciosa entonces queda
un muy buen sabor para grupo británico
pero lo hablaba antes con uno de los
compañeros de la cadena inglesa que es
británico me decía si Inglaterra sale
como salió contra senegal contra Francia
seguramente que para la primera media
hora del partido se encuentre ya con
algún que otro gol ya en desventaja
porque hoy no fue bueno el arranque de
Inglaterra muy lentos kywalker tuvo
muchísimos problemas por la banda
derecha se niega llegó a aprovechar muy
bien esos ataques de ahí esta ocasión de
bulla que salva pickford de manera
memorable destaquemos lo de pickford
porque es lo que le permite Inglaterra
estar con vida o no verse con desventaja
antes de esos goles antes de ese partido
que terminan goleada nos quedamos con el
tres cero pero Inglaterra sabe que no
comenzó bien este encuentro y
precisamente sobre eso quería hablar
Octavio una selección de senegal que
muchos pensaron que podría tal vez la
gran campanada en este partido contra
Inglaterra por momentos manejaron la
pelota manejaron el partido Pero quizás
se quedaron cortos sí desaprovecharon el
primer embrión el primer tiempo en el
que se niega el quizás pudo tener alguna
posibilidad y lo desaprovecharon digamos
con con el desorden táctico que tenía
senegal en la mitad de la cancha sobre
todo perdieron muchas pelotas generaron
que Inglaterra se sintiera cómodo en el
contragolpe le abrieron muchos espacios
atrás y en velocidad y en contragolpe
Inglaterra te liquida tiene jugadores de
muchas jerarquía en ese sector para
marcar la diferencia Y eso es lo que
termina pasando prácticamente los goles
de Inglaterra vienen de errores de
senegal en la salida o de malas entregas
de senegal a la salida que no puede
luego retroceder en velocidad para
alcanzar a los jugadores de de
Inglaterra yo me sigo quedando Luis Juan
con una con una palabra y es jerarquía
la repito porque me parece que aquí está
la diferencia entre Inglaterra y senegal
por más de que los dos puedan pelear
mano a mano la diferencia la hace la
jerarquía de los jugadores no y Y eso
Harry kane Jordan Henderson capitán del
Liverpool con tantísimos partidos de
encima le gran diferencia ante el
entusiasmo de senegal una cosa hubiese
sido ver quizás ha sabido Mané que si
tienes jerarquía enfrentarse a rivales
de ese peso pero acá digamos no solo con
el entusiasmo basta cuando enfrente
tienes a un rival de La potencia
goleadora de Inglaterra no es la
continuación de los octavos de final
este lunes se enfrentarán las elecciones
de Japón y Croacia un duelo atractivo y
que llega luego de la victoria de Japón
sobre España hay mucha paridad en sus
enfrentamientos previos con un triunfo
por lado y un empate en copas del mundo
se han enfrentado en parte ocasiones
Octavio qué podemos esperar de Japón
quizás pueda hacer este equipo el que
nos brinde la primera gran sorpresa de
los octavos de final sí yo digamos sigo
entusiasmado ilusionado por ver
nuevamente a la disciplina japonesa Me
parece que no es casualidad la victoria
frente a Alemania y frente a España no
lo es efectivamente Y creo que es un un
rival
calcado para la de Japón enfrentará
Croacia porque Croacia es el equipo que
va seguramente a manejar el partido
seguramente va a tener la pelota y Japón
es perfecto para contragolpear entonces
me parece que va a ser un partido muy
parejo pero Japón tiene La gran
posibilidad histórica de meterse en
cuartos de final y de seguir peleando en
una llave que es durísima con Argentina
con Países Bajos con Brasil así que me
parece que puede ser el momento de Japón
en otro duelo de la jornada la Selección
de Brasil se estará enfrentando a su
similarte Corea del Sur un partido donde
la historia está del lado del pinta
campeón pero Corea quiere repetir la
actuación de hace 20 años cuando
quedaron entre los cuatro primeros en su
propia Copa del Mundo Juan sabemos que
Brasil es amplio Favorito pero qué se
dice en el entorno respecto a Neymar y
otras lesiones que se han presentado en
el conjunto de Brasil a lo largo de esta
copa del mundo
dijo títere el seleccionador brasileño
en la previa de este encuentro que si
Neymar se encuentra en condiciones
buenas puede comenzar desde el inicio
este encuentro dijo que todo iba a
depender según lo que viera en el último
entrenamiento que celebró la selección
brasileña ya en la noche de Qatar
después de esa rueda de prensa de tite
estaba justamente antes viendo las
imágenes de ese entrenamiento y se vio a
Neymar muy contento se lo vio
participando con naturalidad en esa
sesión con sus compañeros Así que
siguiendo las palabras de tite Neymar
que podría ser inicialista de nuevo y en
el ataque de Brasil se repetiría el 11
que se vio contra Serbia con Lucas
paqueta en el centro del campo y
adelante cuatro delanteros Vinicio del
mar richarlyson y rafinha para este
partido se vio también en esas imágenes
del entrenamiento a Danilo Danilo ya
está a disposición de tite para este
encuentro figura clave por la banda
derecha y el que sigue siendo baja y que
hoy entrenó por separado es alexandro de
ahí ese debate del cual ya hemos hablado
Alex Téllez se lesionó y no puede seguir
en esta copa a quien pondrá a tite para
esa banda izquierda para cuidar los
ataques de humminson todo apunta que
podría repetir con marquiños por ese
Franco
veremos Entonces como resuelve el
seleccionador de Brasil ese compromiso
seguimos con una selección de noticias
de esta copa del mundo
qué acuerdo con el medio español Sport
la federación marroquí de fútbol puso a
la venta 5000 entradas para el partido
de su selección frente a España por los
octavos de final Marruecos la última
selección africana Elisa ha contado con
una gran cantidad de fanáticos en cada
presentación
de acuerdo con Las evaluaciones de la
FIFA según el medio argentino tic Sport
el compromiso entre Uruguay y Corea del
Sur fue uno de los que registró los
niveles más elevados de ruido en lo que
va de la Copa del Mundo Así mismo el
organismo señaló que la selección de
Arabia Saudita ha sido la que llevó la
mayor cantidad de fanáticos a este
mundial
preocupación en Argentina medios de ese
país han señalado que Alejandro Gómez
sufrió un esguince de tobillo por los
que está siendo atendido día a día el
jugador confirmó la lesión Y confesó al
medio tic Sport de ese país que se
recuperará a tiempo para el compromiso
ante Países Bajos por los cuartos de
final
hasta aquí Diario del mundial
agradecemos a Octavio por su
participación también a Juan y a Natalia
desde Qatar los esperamos mañana con un
nuevo especial de esta Copa del Mundo
Mientras tanto sigan con la programación
de France 24 y de France 24 punto com
[Música]